new york times writer frank bruni didn't
think anything about it when he woke up
with blurred vision in one eye this was
back in 2017.
well it turned out he had suffered a
small stroke and would never again be
able to see out of that eye completely
for a professional writer and an avid
reader as you can imagine many thought
this could have been the end of his
former life but in his new book it's
called the beauty of dusk on vision lost
and found we're happy to say rooney
tells us how he gained a new perspective
on perseverance empathy and humanity the
book we should say is published by simon
schuster which is a division of
paramount frank bruni good morning but
we want to also want you know we'd be
doing this book even if it wasn't
division
it is that good frank rooney and it's so
good to see you
so good to see you there's a line in the
book you say when god gives you lemons
take a bow i love that
so take us to that night where you go to
bed and you wake up and you can't see in
one eye what did you think
had happened or was happening to you
well at first i thought that nothing had
happened you know i'm i'm a boomer
generation person you know so i have
that sort of sense of invincibility
which is a false sense and i thought you
know everything's fixable so first i
thought i just had to wash my eye and i
thought no it's my eyeglasses and only
as the hours went on and really into the
next day did i think something might be
wrong you know and then it wasn't
totally or was it was it total darkness
or blackness or what what did it look
like what did it it was as if a dappled
fog had moved into my field of vision
and was over the right side of it and
very very scarily it was making the
words on a computer screen shimmy and
swim and tilt and that was terrifying to
me because as you noted in the intro i
that's my living yeah yeah you know you
go to the doctor and you hear words that
nobody ever wants to hear at the doctor
where she says
this is bad
this is bad and then you're told that
you had a stroke in the eye and part of
the treatment involved an injection
right in the eye frank oh gosh oh god
very hard to read it's in the first
chapter too
take us into what that was like and what
was the purpose of that well that was in
the first two weeks and i decided early
on that i was going to try to be as
active as opposed to passive about what
i was going through and so i qualified
for and enrolled in several experimental
trials and the first one involved
injections into the eye which in the
eyes which are about as pleasant
as they sound
um and the other one i actually had to
learn to inject myself twice a week for
six months but here's the thing i mean
that sounds your people wince it sounds
terrible
i got through all of that and as a
result of that and this is really the
message of the book as a result of that
i learned not how weak and fragile i am
but how strong i am and i think we're
all a lot stronger than we realized well
so wisdom is always hard one but it
usually does not involve an injection
into the eyeball right that is a pretty
high hurdle for wisdom uh but talk a
little bit about what else you learned
emotionally and philosophically about
life i mean in the title dusk does not
mean literal dust it means more than
that no dusk refers sort of the length
of a human day and i feel that when you
get an affliction like this
early-ish in life it's sort of like a
foretaste or a preview of aging of old
age
and it forces you to make a decision
about whether you're going to focus on
what's been taken from you on what's
been lost on your limits or whether
you're going to focus on all the potency
you still have and what remains i think
that's a challenge a kind of fork in the
road that we all encounter when we're
aging and i think it comes to you
earlier if you have a sort of medical
odyssey like mine and i also remember
you sound so rational about this frank
right now i mean you sound so logical
about it you must have had times where
you just freaked out yeah like what the
hell is happening to me and it must have
been scary and terrifying too right now
it does sound very philosophical about
what you learned but in that moment you
certainly couldn't have felt that way i
was scared reading the book for you
there were moments and i was terrified
there were moments that i was when i was
very very angry yeah and there was other
stuff going on in life a ten-year
relationship ended right at that time my
father was going through medical stuff
um so yeah there were moments when i was
really angry but i took a really careful
look around me i surveyed all the people
around me i mean visually surveyed with
my one good eye yeah
and i realized all of us have gone
through pain are in pain have struggled
and so if you do that if you really look
accurately at the world around you you
don't ask why me yeah you ask why not
not me you write something that's very
powerful um you're right we have no
control over what happens to us
we have enormous control over what
happened to us what does that mean to
you
you can as you know as i mentioned
earlier you can decide to stew in what
you believe to be your misfortune
you can do that sort of accounting of
ways in which you've been cheated or
challenged or you can do a different
tally of ways in which you've been
blessed so we talked about writing it is
harder for me to write than it ever was
before i have to budget time and circle
back to check for typos that i never
made but here's the thing people still
want my words you're here talking to me
about a book i've written i choose to
focus on that yeah your best lesson that
you learned in all this
i think my best lesson is about human
nimbleness um i think that we are i like
that we are so much more adaptable than
we realize um i thought i'd never be
able to listen to audiobooks it was
something i couldn't do now i listen to
them on 1.6 speed and that's just a
small thing it's an emblem and a
metaphor and i think if you realize how
nimble and adaptable you are as a human
being um nothing's as scary as it was
you're one of the most nimble writers
working today very elegant very funny as
well we should point that out
it's also in the book where there was
some misdiagnosis that's why i won't
tell you what it is but people really
need to take agency of their own health
don't always believe what the doctor
says but this new york times review out
today may i just read this one sentence
john tower yes thank you
this isn't the sad story of a man who
lost his sight it is a generous
narrative of the student who sought
wisdom when trials appeared in his life
that's you frank rooney really good to
see you looking so good looking so
healthy now teaching journalism at duke
all right i would take your claim thank
you for being so frank rooney the beauty
of dusk goes on sale tomorrow wherever
you like to buy your books